all right so Scream Six is tearing its
way through theaters right now all
Ghostface called up his pal Jason and
got a one-way ticket to the Big Apple
Yip Woodsboro is in the rear view mirror
this time around as the core for the
surviving members from Scream 5 have
even bigger threats to deal with this
time around the Times Square Elmos
so in this video we're gonna be gutting
this thing open for y'all who's behind
the ghost face mask who makes it out
alive what a scream 7 may look like and
of course a reaction in review for this
meta slasher spooky movie all sorts of
heavy spoilers in this Fright Fest
breakdown so a huge thank you for
clicking this I'm your helpless victim I
mean host Jared so pick up your phone
and let me know what's your favorite
scary movie
foreign
so Scream 6 picks up roughly a year
after the events of Scream 5 as we get
the obligatory scream opening kill which
involves Samara weaving's Laura crane a
black Moore film Professor trying to
meet a Tinder date she's lured into a
dark alley by her date and then brutally
stabbed to death should have swiped left
but shocker Ghostface removes his mask
like minutes into the movie and it's
Tony revelori's Jason Carvey emphasis on
carb as it's revealed he and his
roommate Greg strive to finish what
Richie started Die Hard stab fans and
want Tara and Sam dead yet again another
surprise as another Ghostface calls
Jason taunting him into finding his
roommates disembodied corpse in the
fridge and then stabs Jason as a unique
twist pull the rug from underneath the
viewers We Now find out Mindy Chad and
Tara attend Blackmore College as Sam M
tags along to be the protective Guardian
for Terra however Sam is in therapy
because of her killer tendencies that
seem to be growing every day and she she
kind of likes it this drives Dr Stone
he's from Mission Impossible if you
remember to drop her as a client
threatening to report this to
authorities the new members joining the
core four turn out to be Annika who is
dating Mindy Ethan who is a random
roommate with Chad and Quinn the fiery
sex positive roommate of both Tara and
Sam Sam heads out to a frat party to
meet with them but it soon realized
rumors have spread all the way across
the country that Sam was the actual
Woodsboro killer because she's Billy
loomis's daughter and used Richie as a
scapegoat as Sam is a bit of a celebrity
amongst the youths they watch a news
report covering the Ghostface killings
from the opening scene and discovered
that a ghost face mask was left at the
crime seen like some sort of calling
card Quinn calls her father detective
Wayne Brady
no it is not Wayne Brady Wayne Bailey oh
my gosh who mentioned Sam needs to get
to the station ASAP because her driver's
license was found at the scene of the
crime feeling something isn't right Sam
urges Tara they must leave the city
until she gets a call from Richie's
phone but wait a minute that some beach
died in Scream five this can't be it's
Ghost Face though telling her to watch
her back jumping out and chasing them
into a bodega this is the whole stab
stab shotgun boom scene from the trailer
they escape police show up and Ghostface
yet again leaves another mask at the
crime scene this drives the pair to the
station for some questioning with Sam
saying it's impossible Richie could have
called her because she pin cushioned him
stabbing him 22 times however
questioning is cut short by the FBI and
that agent happens to be Kirby read yes
the best scream character ever is back
baby now working for the FBI studying
Ghostface ever since she nearly survived
in screamed 4. enter Gale weathers as
her and a handful of reporters are
outside of the station Sam and Tara have
beef with Gail because she promised she
wouldn't write about the events of
Scream 5 but ended up doing so anyway so
Tara gives her some Sweet Chin Music
there's a quick scene of Dr Stone being
murdered by Ghostface who then steals
Sam's file and leaves yet again another
mask at the scene shouldn't these be in
police evidence or something yes you're
right the movie even says this anyway
Mindy then informs the core for and
everyone else that they are no longer in
a recoil but rather a sequel to a recall
AKA a franchise so absolutely no one is
safe there are no rules of course this
drives the crew to be a bit more
cautious staying in for the evening it's
revealed that Sam and Danny you know pug
from She-Hulk they're across the way
neighbor have a secret relationship
going on with one another anyway Danny
Witnesses Quinn being stabbed by
Ghostface in her room he tries to warn
the others in the living room but they
just think the banging is some sort of
hella kinky bedroom stuff from Quinn
Ghostface moves from Quinn's room to the
living room stabbing Annika as they try
to escape via a makeshift ladder from
their apartment to Danny's everyone
makes it out except Annika who is shook
from the ladder falling face first into
a dumpster again another mask is left at
the scene of the crime as detective
bayley arrives shattered seeing his
daughter be claimed by Ghostface he
makes a comment about losing both of his
children hint hint audience members as
he swears revenge on Ghostface Gail
shows up mentioning she has some new
information that could help leading them
to the Grand Ghost Face Shrine that is
featured in the trailers packed with
loads of Easter eggs and memorabilia
from the previous five Scream movies
Gail adds that this theater was listed
under Jason and Greg's names the two
dudes that were claimed by another ghost
face in the opening they come up with a
plan to trace ghost Face's phone because
Kirby can do this I guess in under 15
seconds not to brag which actually
traces the phone to Gail's apartment
Gail's new boy toy is axed as she puts
up a good fight even pulling the old
star 69 trick to Auto call back ghost
Face's phone but is ultimately stabbed
with a large Shard of glass the final
plan sees them luring Ghostface back to
the shrine theater blocking all the
exits and giving him the business
however the group is separated via the
subway and with it being Halloween night
there are a bevy of mass characters out
and about Ethan and Mindy are the two
separated resulting in Mindy Bean's
staff stabbed by a rogue Ghost Face
Ethan then helps her but Mindy is out of
commission for the third act back at the
theater Sam Taps into her Supernatural
ghost Billy Powers telling her to grab
his knife for protection but every bit
of their plan falls apart with Bailey
calling Sam to let her know that Kirby
wasn't working for the FBI for at least
the last two months she can't be trusted
Ghostface appears starting the climactic
chase sequence as a video of Richie's
plays on the projector Chad is caught
off guard stabbed multiple times by
Ghostface then another Ghost Face shows
up tag team Chad Eiffel towering him
essentially turning him into swiss
cheese detective bayley shows up
shooting Kirby in the shoulder and
reveals himself to be one of the ghost
face Killers along with his son Ethan
what and daughter Quinn what a Twist who
didn't die earlier it was all staged and
all three were related to Richie being
his father and siblings making this one
big family affair Revenge trip
I am speechless I am without speech
Quinn had started all of the Sam rumors
originally to ruin her reputation as the
second part of their plan was to frame
Sam for all of the murders in Scream 5.
essentially assassinate her character
and cancel her it's a big old Scooby-Doo
chase scene as the family goes up
against Sam and Tara Tara best Ethan by
stabbing him through the mouth like
hella brutal even twisting it while Sam
shoots Quinn in the head easily taking
them out and after falling from the
balcony and passing out Bailey regains
composure now being hunted by Sam
wearing Billy loomis's Ghost Face
costume Sam Thompson using the classic
voice changer until she attacks him on
stage stabbing him furiously like she
did to Richie in Scream 5. the final
blow to Bailey is a gruesome knife to
the eye that I did not
see coming
surprisingly all of the OG cast Gale
Mindy Chad survive which you just gotta
suspend your disbelief here as the final
scene sees Sam staring at Billy's ghost
face mask being called to the darkness
she instead tosses it aside following
Tara back into the city which totally
sets up the mask to return in like a gym
carry the mask scenario for the sequel
now just don't leave yet because Scream
6 has a post-credit scene baby yes the
first of the franchise following the
trend of every single movie needing a
post-credits scene now but at least they
are taking the piss out of things with
this one as the scene opens on Mindy
Meeks from earlier in the movie talking
about the franchise rules of the movie
that they are in now saying not every
movie needs a post-credit scene as it
turns to black and the movie ends it's
some something but not not really at
least the radio silence team is sticking
with the times and this is a clever joke
in the grander meta scheme of things but
is totally on par with the lame
Spider-Man homecoming postcarded scene
where Cap basically pulls the same
gimmick tongue-in-cheek poking fun at
whoever is still watching now one of the
biggest absences from Scream 6 was the
scream queen that started it all Sydney
Prescott AKA Nev Campbell unfortunately
her character does not have any screen
time but is it at least mentioned in
passing a couple of times according to
the movie The reason she doesn't make
the trip to the big old Apple is because
due to the news of more ghost face
killings she took her husband Mark oh hi
Mark and children into hiding until the
ghost face news blows over so at least
the film acknowledged her missing in
action even if it's a hey turned screen
and tell the audience directly what is
happening with this beloved care
character however outside of the movie
sphere a different reason exists for
Campbell not appearing and it was purely
over contract and pay disputes back in
June of 2022 Campbell announced that she
would be stepping back from the scream
franchise saying sadly I won't be making
the next scream film as a woman I've had
to work extremely hard in my career to
establish my value especially when it
comes to scream I felt the offer that
was presented to me did not equate to
the value I've brought to the franchise
this doesn't mean she's done forever she
could pop back up and scream seven if
her family is threatened but to me it
just feels like the script didn't allow
for a place for this character so yeah
sad to see but it kinda makes sense as
for a potential Scream 7 at the time of
editing this there has been no official
word on a sequel there have been a
handful of rumor articles claiming that
the shooting of Scream 7 is happening
later this year while also mentioning
that early reviews and the tracking box
office numbers obviously signal that
there is a thirst for more Ghostface
even with the radio silence crew chiming
in on their eagerness to pick up the
mask for another go is there a scream
seven idea out there
we want to be watching three movies
whether we're involved or not for the
rest of our lives you know so if it were
up to you the idea is to continue the
franchise absolutely
so if you know that there's gonna be but
if there is a scream seven what is it
going to entail well with Sam
essentially being called to the Billy
mask like some sort of Dr Jekyll and Mr
Hyde character I can see Sam potentially
falling to that Darkness essentially a
loose cannon not knowing if she would
turn on her friends or not or even going
off on her own to scratch the ghost face
itch maybe that's too easy of a guess
but you know damn well that they're
going to go International with a sequel
soon a completely different environment
for Ghostface to play hell even a ghost
face on a plane scenario
[Music]
but I could see this also leaning into
social media a bit more potentially
people trying to become social media
Famous by staging Ghost Face attacks and
then it's discovered that there have
been two killers the whole time no
surprise there but but follow me here
they aren't connected and have been
stepping on one another's plans
throughout the entire movie like some
goofy who's on first Looney Tune sketch
also I'm surprised an actual stab movie
show spin-off or short hasn't been
experimented with there could be a
market maybe of of them basically
parroting their own films but as for
Scream 6 it's a bloody good time is it
the best in the franchise probably not
is it the worst far from and I think two
things that radio silence really honed
in on this time around was the
brutalness of the kills and the tension
of Ghostface like you feel and hear the
heaviness of the knife gouges especially
when there's multiple in a row but man
the tension of slowly going through a
scene knowing ghost's face is gonna pop
out at any moment was timed perfectly
not overstaying its welcome and not
being premature sure is it another
predictable Scream movie yeah pretty
much I mean there's are only so many
Liberties you can take with the same
formula but I didn't guess all of the
killers so I guess there's still a
couple surprises I think the biggest
thing that didn't work for me was the
ending felt a bit rushed and
anti-climactic like the motives that
they had made sense but also were just
like yeah okay cool and the meta nature
of things felt a bit too heavy-handed
like show don't tell because there's a
lot of now I'm announcing this is a meta
thing because this happened before be
subtle baby I'll give a little Scream
Six a solid 7 out of 10 Ghost Face
attacks I had fun with this one and it
does exactly what I wanted a Scream
movie to do the cat past shined a bit
more here than in five and I'm intrigued
to see where these new relationships
take them also there's a really cool
shot of two ghost faces just cleaning
their blades frame that anyway I'd love
to hear your thoughts on Scream Six was
the brutal and meta Direction everything
you had hoped for or was this just more
of the same ghost face just doing his
Ghost Face stuff and I'll let you know
we're currently running the competition
giving away three copies of the rocky 4K
box set on the 15th of March and all you
gotta do to get a chance of winning this
is like this video subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below on your thoughts on Scream Six we
picked the comments at random at the end
of every single month and the winners of
last month are on screen right now so if
that's you message us on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch be sure to check out some
of our other cool videos right over
there we've been cranking them out this
week but with all of that out of the way
thank you for your constant support I've
been Jared I'll see in the next one take
care and what's your favorite scary
movie